yeah for sure
um for you
obviously a guy like Uzi is you know if
he's on the show he's headlining the
[__] roll him out he's he's he is
having a moment yeah again for sure over
and over he has these moments where it's
like no uzi's [__] Superstar Rockstar
for real for real
um you guys had kind of gotten to like a
weird patch in your relationship which
I'm sure happens a lot when artists sign
and like I I sympathize with kind of the
label side because it's like you know
you put all these resources behind the
guy you kind of put it put all the chips
onto somebody and once they pop you know
they start to be like well you know what
the [__] you guys seem to have gotten
over whatever weird hump you had because
I see pictures you guys together what's
your guys's relationship now it's great
um until we got over the hump you know
we're back in a in a a great working
space and a great personal space
um him and Canon have been working you
know very very hard on the pink tape I'm
looking forward to that and you know
like it like it's family's bicker you
know what I'm saying and like you said
like you know sometimes it plays out in
the public sometimes it doesn't and you
know like for us you know obviously
again like you said we've put so much
time and invested so much and like you
know his success is our success so even
at a space and time where we may differ
or you know I don't agree or have
another opinion on it it's like it's
it's a rock in our place because it's
like you know the bigger he is the
better it is for you absolutely so you
know it's kind of like you just gotta
you know roll with the punches and and
you know
keep putting that work in you know
obviously for us a great thing that
happened too when we were getting a lot
of the the uh brunt of the you know bad
publicity or bad press like with The
Rock Nation situation and all that [__]
it was like
Jack Harlow came and it was like okay
these guys really know what they're
doing like shout out to study Hendrix
too you know what I'm saying so you know
and we've we've been quite successful
and you know what I mean um and and
honestly like I've been in the game so
long and it's like I've weathered so
many storms so even with diverse [__]
it's like you know I'm
you you you hope and you you know
foresee like yo we'll get past this what
was like the Catalyst to you guys kind
of repairing that relationship
um time yeah yeah time it was you know
just coming you know coming back and you
know I guess it's like
after a couple years of of
things kind of like letting it play out
it just you know we got back in a good
space and again you know we were we were
moving and grooving like generation now
like
and you see this guy right here Jack
Harlow
we got some things going I never
understood the Rock Nation thing because
I always like thought to myself like
it's not like you Lake and Don Cannon
aren't of the culture
who the [__] you are say it again so I
was like yo say it again why aren't why
is it Roc Nation to try to pull people
out of deals from like actual culture
vultures say it again DJ Drama like like
you try to [__] pull my guy out of
like like he's like he found this kid
you know what I'm saying like DJ Drama
did not pay bootleg Kev to make such an
accurate statement now as soon as that
happened I was like
there's people who you should Advocate
to get out of deals say it again but
we're talking about Don Cannon drama and
Lake come on bro like
three young black successful
men who met in college at the ages of 18
and 19
hbcus by the way and made a name for
themselves within the hip-hop culture
for two decades Paving the way and
putting on and providing for the culture
like huh yeah of anybody that should
have been embraced or it should have did
the way it played out that like I didn't
see them advocating to like get a Meek
Mill released off at Atlantic after he
complained about how he didn't like his
deal right
this [__] that was an adult anyway shout
out to Uzi he's a [__] Legend
absolutely